[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 60,18
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire du 7-8
société où on débat on discute et on
réfléchit sur des sujets qui font
l'actualité
entre 8 et 11 millions de français sont
aujourd'hui des aidants comprenait des
nous professionnels qui viennent en aide
à une personne dépendante de leur
entourage alors si depuis le 1er octobre
2020 tous les aidants la possibilité de
prendre des congés rémunérés
quel soutien pour ces aidants dans les
yvelines on en parle avec nos invités
olivier calon bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
président de l'institut nationale des
aidants et membre du cdc à des yvelines
le conseil départemental de la
citoyenneté et de l'autonomie à voix
camara bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
président de second souffle une
association accompagnant les parents
d'enfants en situation de handicap les
béatrice ben oui bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes chargé de prévention perte
d'autonomie au département des yvelines
alors quand on parle d' adam des dents
on pense très souvent une personne au
chevet de son père ou de sa mère
tout du moins un ascendant mais olivier
calon un aidant et comme je le disais et
celui qui aident un proche
même un enfant un descendant alors tout
à fait la notion de lennon et est très
large
elle concerne en fait toute personne qui
va accompagner quelqu'un à vulnérabilité
que ça soit va suite à une maladie que
ce soit suite à un handicap ou où
effectivement avec le vieillissement de
la population une personne en perte
d'autonomie
donc il faut bien voir cette notion le
proche aidant en tant qu'individu il
fait partie de la famille c'est un
voisin c'est quelqu'un qui vient une
façon récurrente à un an moins bien
précis aider à satisfaire si vous voulez
les besoins de la vie quotidienne de
lénine et c'est un statut qui est devenu
officiel visible en 2019 avec la loi du
22 mai qu'est ce que ça change cette
visibilité
olivier calon oui
en fait les dents a toujours existé il
est souvent invisible
la mère de famille avec son enfant au
père de famille est naturelle mais c'est
vrai que de plus en plus le
vieillissement de la population fait
qu'on a de plus en plus de personnes
dépendantes et il y avait aussi ce sujet
important du handicap qui lui en 2005 a
vu une reconnaissance importante
donc aujourd'hui on peut dire qu'on a
une loi qui concerne 11 millions de
personnes
donc ça fait quand même beaucoup de
monde que ce soit des personnes actives
ou des personnes d'ailleurs retraités
maintenant il faut que les droits avance
il faut qu'il reconnaisse si tous autant
que nous sommes nous sommes tous des
pays d'en haut nous allons devenir des
aidants donc voilà chacun de progresser
par rapport à aujourd'hui
on fait beaucoup de choses au niveau là
la france des régions et des
départements
à vos camarades vous êtes vous même une
aidante vous accompagner votre enfant
quand est ce que vous vous êtes rendez
compte que vous n'était pas seulement
une maman mais un et d'en bas c'est vrai
comme le dit monsieur taillon je crois
que dans les chiffres il ya quelques
chansons 2 % des aidants qui seront dans
l'espace comme tel les rats ont dit que
c'est naturel
les dés sont proches et moi je m'en suis
rendu compte à la radio j'avais entendu
parler de ce terme par le sociologue
serge guérin
j'avais pas entendu le cerveau
auparavant et surtout par les
conséquences ont ce statut cette
position en tout cas on prenne
on m'a pas voilà le fait d'être parent
est dans le fait qu'on accompagne notre
enfant sur une longue période ce qui
crée des conséquences est la notion des
dogues pour moi est aussi synonyme de
cette constatation vie privée vie
familiale avec le jumeau c'est dur de
même de parfois jongler entre les deux
cette fatigue
tout ce qui va voir les conséquences au
niveau financier tout ce qui va avoir au
niveau de l'information du soutien qu'on
doit avoir au quotidien fait que petit à
petit bas en parallèle de ce terme
il ya des conséquences qui peuvent
conduire parfois jusqu'à l'épuisement
alors vous avez choisi de fonder une
association second souffle à la compagne
les parents comme vous pourquoi cette
association
l'idée en tout cas de second saut chez
tout début c'était vraiment se rendre
compte que les parents pour pouvoir
continuer sur du long terme sans
s'essouffler avait besoin de moments de
répit des moments de pause de second
souffle c'est par rapport au sport et à
un moment on a encore en cours et on
reprend à ceux d'en dessous pour finir
un petit peu notre course mais là c'est
un peu ça c'était comment aider les
familles à reprendre un petit que du
compte de la bête par des ateliers de
sophro par des ateliers cuisine par des
connaissances sur leurs droits par des
moments où on se regroupe pouvait
changer un petit peu aussi nos repères
nos bons plans et c'est donc avec cette
association elle est venue d'un besoin a
pas être isolé a pas se retrouver seul
mais surtout de ré ont également aux
difficultés du quotidien et à cette
notion vraiment de deux pauses bois mais
il ya plus des dents qu'on pourrait le
penser béatrice bouillé les aidant dans
les yvelines sont environ 2 environ par
nos 230 milles est ce que c'est un
chiffre conséquent
oui c'est un chiffre important alors
c'est un chiffre qu'on a du mal à
estimer précisément on est reparti en
fait de ce pourcentage coocoonhome
nationale pour l'appliquer aux yvelinois
est aujourd'hui bas comme le disait
dessus kalou madame camara on a du mal à
se reconnaître et dans donc il n'y a pas
de statistiques précises sur qui sont
les aidants mais voilà au regard du
nombre de personnes âgées en cette
chaude handicap accompagne dans les
yvelines effectivement voilà on est à
peu près sûr sur ce nombre d'aidants et
voilà avec un enjeu de les aider et de
effectivement mieux faire connaître
l'ensemble des réponses qui existe pour
que les soulager au mieux les
accompagner et leur faire saisir va
toutes les opportunités qui peuvent se
présenter pour voilà être au plus proche
de leurs proches en difficulté en étant
soutenue
oui mais camara là du tout à l'heure
souvent la question financière arrive
très vite alors nous chaque semaine on
pose une question à nos téléspectateurs
et on voulait savoir s'il fallait
rémunérer ces aidants 91 % des votants
ont répondu oui
olivier calon il existe des aides
financières pour les aidants des
indemnités des congés notamment le congé
proches aidants c'est la mesure phare de
agir pour les et les aidants la
stratégie de mobilisation 2020 2022
c'est quel impact financier pour
quelqu'un qui va aider sont proches on
s'arrête de travailler on passe en temps
partiel c'est si ça va vous poser la
question c'est un tout c'est une
nouvelle existence régie est
pratiquement à financer fait de maintien
en forme parce que faut résister pour
parler des puissants c'est
l'accompagnement allait faire des taxis
faire le lien avec les dents et ddc se
substituer à l'ailé c'est très difficile
c'est vraiment des cas particuliers à
chaque fois et qu'il faut effectivement
que les villes départements de zatanna
la chose de manière très très forte
si ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
dents au niveau de la valeur en tant que
tel avec serge guérin justement d'en
parler c'est c'est aujourd'hui c'est
entre guillemets du bénévolat mais c'est
des heures passées et si comptablement
vous parler en terme d'heure et c'est
pratiquement 100 milliards donc c'est
énorme et je dirais que c'est pour ça
qu'il faut bien trouver ses ressources
et cette richesse
ça permettra de répondre là c'est un peu
technique mais c'est quand même le
cinquième risque qui vient d'être votée
donc le financement de l'autonomie et si
vous si on arrive à soulever entre
guillemets c'est c'est tous ces aidants
et à les aider
ça va être une richesse d'autant plus
pour pour tout le monde alors le montant
ne lâche pas l'allocation journalière du
proches aidants est fixé à 40 un peu
plus un peu moins pardon de 44 euros par
jour pour les personnes vivant en couple
un peu plus de 52 euros pour une
personne seule à voit qu'à masquer c'est
suffisant est-ce que c'est gratifiant
après je pense que cela m'avait parlé au
niveau des parents
les dents c'est vrai que dans le cadre
second souffle on met en place des
permanences d'accueil sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines où on
accueille des parents pour répondre à
leurs questions est ce qu'on s'aperçoive
c'est quand même dans les parents qu'on
reçoit beaucoup ne connaissent pas leurs
droits
faux répond la même question le montant
qui a été attribué pour le projet
proches aidants correspond à peu près à
la location présence parentale qui
existe pour les les parents dont je
pense que voilà c'est quelque chose qui
a été fier pour un petit peut être un
peu sur le même montant donc comme
disait monsieur canon je pense qu'il ya
autant dire autant des dents que
situation finalement les regards pour
certaines familles où ce montant va être
suffisant pour d'autres je n'étais pas
quelqu'un qui avait des revenus plus
importants où ça va d'abord quand même
une perte de revenus d'autres quand même
et beaucoup de mamans ont arrêté leur
emploi donc forcément ça va avoir une
conséquence sur leur quotidien sur leur
pouvoir d'achat
moi même je suis maman d'un enfant
polyhandicapé le polyhandicap coûte cher
dans le centre où il faut équiper sa
maison il faut pouvoir avoir du matériel
particulier ça coûte de l'argent et
forcément si un indé de découpe un dans
le couple arrêtent de travailler aussi
on se retrouve en monoparentalité ça va
avoir un ça m'a pesé financièrement donc
répondre à vos questions c'est compliqué
dans le sens où ou parfois ce n'est pas
suffisant parfois oui ça peut l'être en
transition d'une autre situation c'est
vraiment un bon sens du caire marc hein
mais la trésorerie on a vu madame camara
l'a dit on est aussi parfois pas informé
de ses droits
est-ce que vous aussi au département
vous allez au devant pour informer vous
aussi à une aide financière qui est
proposée au niveau du département
alors le département sur les aides
financières ne fait pas mieux que les
réglementations nationales voilà on
s'aligne aujourd'hui sur les
propositions qui sont faites au national
et sur l'information
on a pris conscience de cet enjeu et
notamment à travers un groupe de
réflexion auquel participent madame
camara monsieur calon les enjeux sont
énormes et donc on est en train de
réfléchir à ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
un centre ressource alors peut-être que
le nom sera pas celui là
en tout cas effectivement il ressort un
vrai besoin de d'avoir un endroit bien
identifiés pour les gens pour
effectivement trouver l'information se
renseigner et ensuite que cette première
bordant très bien identifié permettre
d'orienter vers les bonnes réponses
aujourd'hui il existe les pôles
autonomie territoriaux qui voit là avec
des noms un peu jargonnant disent pas
grand chose à des gens qui n'y
arriverais voilà dans ce milieu qui est
le médico-social l'accompagnement des
publics en autonomie donc on va chercher
réfléchir à une porte d'entrée plus
facilement repérables permettra
effectivement ensuivent de bien orienter
et d'en informer le mieux possible
l'ensemble des parents enfants qui
recherchent des informations et
l'information existe il faut qu'on
affine voit la terminologie et des
réflexions sens pas vous le disiez tous
les trois on l'a bien entendu c est très
dense et quasiment du 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 alors dans une une enquête
nationale de ipsos pour la macif
parmi les impacts il a bien sûr l'un
financier mais aussi l'impact moral
50 % des aidants se sentent seuls 62%
ressentent un état d'épuisement intense
béatrice buis à nouveau à vous il y à
des groupes des doses et donc qui
interviennent sur tout le territoire il
exactement le alors il ya beaucoup
d'initiatives de parents à l'image de ce
que madame camara pu mettre en place et
puis effectivement le département au
sein de ces toujours de ces pôles
autonomie territoriaux qu'on appelle les
pattes ils sont installés au plus près
des habitants dans les territoires
organise des groupes de parole que ce
soir concours des aidants de parent âgé
ou des étangs de d'enfants en situation
de handicap
les associations aussi qui accompagnent
ces familles et ses enfants ont succombé
les offres qu'ils existent voilà il ya
on a la chance dans les yvelines d'avoir
une offre importante grâce à la prise
d'initiative et de parents les gars
traction est donc l'enjeu c'est
maintenant effectivement que les gens
aient accès à toute cette offre existe
et qui est on a de la chance dans les
îles une importante
olivier calon
voit aussi sur certains territoires
comme saint quentin en yvelines des
moments où les aidants peuvent faire du
off est revoir leurs proches pris en
charge pour s'accorder du temps est ce
que vous sentez que les communes les
institutions prennent aussi conscience
qui est donc c'est très ce qu'un métier
voire c'est un métier là on parle de
toute l'action sociale d'une manière
générale côté effectivement des
sanitaires et médico social nous on
prodigue des programmes pédagogiques
d'information justement auprès des
aidants qui est tout à fait je dirais
pas inédit mais c'est tout ça c'est
nouveau
parce qu'il fallait s'y colle et bien
sûr la loi et au plan agir pour les
aidants et aux dispositifs territoriaux
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
chemin à faire
que ça soit dans cet accompagnement pour
les élus au niveau des municipalités
donc ça soit effectivement sur le
territoire pour saint quentin en
yvelines
vous avez des agglomérations au sinistre
groupe qui peut avoir ses compétences
d'accompagner les aidants d'ailleurs je
crois que saint quentin en yvelines est
membre de la conférence des financeurs
madame oui donc aussi peu sa forme et à
travers ça mais c'est vrai qu'il ya tout
un travail en véritablement profondeur
sachant que aussi tous les dispositifs
change en permanence il va taxer c'est
pas très simple donc je crois qu'il faut
aller directement auprès de la mairie
des ccs il ya des choses à travailler
pas mal
awa camara vous même en tant qu'aide ont
aussi de voir que les institutions
créneau commence à peine à prendre en
charge cette notion est ce que ça il ya
ainsi un soulagement vous savez que vous
pouvez vous reposer sur quelqu'un
d'autre qu'un ami cas un membre de votre
famille après je pense que vraiment
comme on dit tout à l'heure je pense
qu'il ya quand même une vraie
méconnaissance pour ça dans de ce qui
est dit sur le territoire il ya beaucoup
de nigériens voilà c'est la prestation
de compensation handicap de là je parle
plus que les parents haut niveau sur des
parents d'enfants scolarisés par exemple
une heure par jour
gan il ya des aides qui existent qui
s'entremêlent avec la réalité du terrain
qui font que parfois franchement c'est
un sais pas si vide rocla de trouver le
bon interlocuteur la bonne aide et pour
les parents d'identifier réellement de
quoi il a besoin et ça c'est pas c'est
pas fameux
oui ça serait finie qu'il existe des
choses et c'est super et ça ira de mieux
en mieux je pense mais il faut aller les
chercher ses dépens il faut que aussi
arrive à s'identifier
il faut deux lettres de proximité il
faut pouvoir être à leur écoute
il faut que dans les entreprises y est
aussi comme le disait monsieur qualité
tout à l'heure on est tous des énormes
potentiels la population vieillit voilà
il ya un an je pense qu il peut avoir
mis en difficulté et c'est vrai qu'à
partir du moment où on est tous
potentiellement concernés ça devient un
enjeu national de société on doit tous
s'y mettre en fait et le monde dans
l'entreprise où on sait qu'un intentions
5 pardon en étant sûrs d'eux est dans le
trou de l'entreprise pour pas perdre ses
salariés qui ont des compétences qui ont
du potentiel
il faut pouvoir adapter les choses là la
corrida a bien montré que le télétravail
était possible en vue c'est pas tout le
monde et il y en a beaucoup qui sont
fatigués du télétravail mais avant c'est
quelque chose qui était compliqué pour
des aidants de pouvoir négocier avec
leur employeur
juste du télétravail on voit qu'il ya
des choses des choses qui sont possibles
pour ac les aidants soient soit donc dû
présenter ou de la santé lise prennent
des jours de congé par ci par là et au
bout d'un moment arrête de travailler
donc je pense qu'il ya tout un
engagement national citoyen chacun doit
faire un peu sa part pour que l'on
puisse proposer des choses pérenne et
qui ait du sens pour que les étrangers
soient bien dans leurs baskets quoi un
étang qui va bien il pourra correctement
accompagné second proche s'il va pas
bien bah voila je crois qu'il ya une
étude qui disait surtout pour les
aidants de personnes âgées qu'on perd 10
ans d'espérance de vie
donc il faut il faut il faut qu'on
prenne soin de nous olivier canon je
vous ai vu à casser plusieurs fois de
face aux propos de la voix camara se ce
congé de garde
de garder dans pardon ça permet de
quitter son poste plus facilement aussi
c'est une avancée en fait on parle de
négociations d'entreprise
quand vous parliez d'accords salariaux
pour trouver justement ces élans les
accompagner qui s'assoit le congé proche
aidant il y aller donc de rtt il ya les
dombes congé il ya des cesu chèque
emploi service rh comme on dit tout
plein de dispositifs ont parlé de deux
départements veiller aussi l'entreprise
qui a tous ces dispositifs qui peuvent
mettre en place mais ça c'est un accord
d'entreprise qui qu'il faut trouver
d'ailleurs la loi un rempart et le plan
agir pour les aidants parle aussi mais
c'est vrai que depuis un an à parce
qu'on voulait mais souligne mme kaba
tiens justement ce télétravail qui
libéré justement du temps pour pour
l'aider avec les dents mais ça ça c'est
complètement arrêté ces accords il ya
même un label aujourd'hui qui existent
pour accompagner les aidants en
entreprise là il faut pour travailler ce
sujet concilier vie personnelle et vie
professionnelle
c'est important et tu peux tête du
département aussi on a fait une caravane
tous et dont il ya depuis le 5 février
dernier des web ateliers pour alléger
cette fameuse charge mentale
vous pouvez nous expliquer un peu madame
ben oui mais c'est dans cette idée de
maintenir le lien malgré cette
incapacité de pouvoir se réunir
madame camara parlait de cette entraide
qui est importante
voilà de pouvoir se donner des trucs et
astuces de pouvoir aussi déposé un peu
la difficulté les phares de comporter et
donc le a été encouragé la continuité
des groupes d'échangés de 2 malgré le
fait qu'on puisse pas se retrouver en
présentiel et donc une bonne partie de
l'offre a pu être proposées en systèmes
de des changes à distance au web
et donc voilà c'est dans la continuité
de ce qui est proposé c'est pouvoir
continuer à échanger à déposer ses
difficultés puis à pouvoir échanger avec
des gens qui peuvent vivre la même
situation soit on a parlé de l'impact
fut là c'est l'impact montagne est ce qu
on pourrait aussi
pour aider ces aidants envisager une
formation parce que aider un proche en
perte d'autonomie ans en situation de
handicap c'est pas nécessairement
naturel les professionnels eux ont des
formations dédiées aux soins à la
toilette à l'apprentissage est ce qu'on
pourrait changer aussi statut pour
peut-être en fait en faire un jour un
métier reconnu avoir camara par exemple
alors ça existe je pense y avait il ya
des formations des barreaux il ya des
formations pour les managers
il ya des choses qui existent de ce côté
là il ya aussi tout un processus là où
je crois qu'il ya un an
le diplôme d'état alors je me rappelle
plus trop du nom ou en fait qu'à des
aidants qui peuvent sous forme de vae
faire reconnaître aussi leurs
compétences pour des métiers du travail
social autres donc il ya des choses qui
vont avancer
il ya des choses ou sa simple je pensais
être aidant c'est de toute façon un
moment avoir des savoir-faire et des
compétences qui doivent être valorisés
parce que parce que c'est vraiment je
pense que je reviendrai au monde de
l'entreprise mais pas que quand on est
capable de gérer des les emplois du
temps qui ne sont pas les siens à
l'étang des rendez vous médicaux quérir
des termes médicaux complets seraient
pas au début mais plein de compétences
en place qui peut avec une richesse
réellement pour l'entreprise je crois
que c'est valoriser dans votre pays par
exemple la partie moment où on dit qu'on
est dedans on sait qu'on a un plus dans
d'autres pays en france c'est plus
compliqué c'est comme si ça va être une
tare fils ouhlala elles avaient toutes
parts absente
je vais j'ai pas la prendre alors que
non et des réelles
donc pour répondre à votre question je
suis parti un peu plus moi oui je pense
qu'il ya de toute façon il ya des
formations
il faut continuer nous sur ce second
souffre on fait de la 106 aussi par le
théâtre on a créé une pièce de théâtre
qui a permis tant qu'a été ouvert aux
professionnels
on sait que en parler
il ya comme difficultés mais aussi comme
ce qui a comme force de ses parents ou
du cédant en général c'est aussi vous
permettent de vous montrer les choses
pour les faire exister et du coup de
pouvoir après apporter une aide sur
mesure
mais voilà je le paysage je sais que
entre l'hyper centre
enfin voilà nouveau souffle il ya pas
mal de choses qui existent aux
territoires où il ya des formations qui
existent
béatrice vous et quelles seraient les
prochaines choses à mettre en place au
département vous avez parlé du centre de
ressources est ce qu'il ya d'autres
projets dans les cartons dans les
yvelines
et alors on a la chance d'avoir vad et
des acteurs très engagé qui voit là ne
perdent pas l'idée d'améliorer encore et
toujours les réponses rire les aidants
et donc on a plein de projets dans les
tuyaux il ya la mise en place d'un
carnet à destination des professionnels
pour qu'ils aillent il ya de façon
systématique ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le réflexe aidant c'est à
dire que quand un professionnel
s'adresse à une famille et tout de suite
il se pose la question aussi et comme en
valais dans voilà où est ce qu'il en est
de sa reconnaissance de son état de
santé et permettent aux professionnels
de systématiquement voilà orienter les
aidants et les aider dans les réponses
quand aujourd'hui souvent les
professionnels s'attache à aider l'aider
mais moins les dents donc voilà la
formation des professionnels avec ce
carnet d'ailleurs madame camara à la fin
du carnet on allait très certainement
imaginé pouvoir solliciter les aidants
qui le souhaitent dans la peur et dans
cette idée de voile à pouvoir
transmettre le savoir acquis il ya cette
situation des danses pour accompagner
d'autres peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas
encore voilà la chance d'avoir trouvé
des solutions pour leurs proches et puis
donc ce l'amélioration de la lisibilité
voilà des réponses à apporter avec cette
réflexion sur le centre ressources la
couverture du territoire aussi sur des
solutions qui existent qui s'appelle des
plateformes de répit qui sont des
réponses aujourd'hui plus doit dessiner
s'ils ont des proches de personnes
malades des maladies qu'on appelle neuro
dégénératives voilà aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines
il ya certains par territoires qui ne
sont pas bien faire voilà donc renforcer
la lisibilité de l'information couvrir
tout le territoire et former les
professionnels
voilà les gleek olivier canon vous
souhaitez réagir
oui par rapport le futur on parle de
nouveaux métiers autour de la vie donc
ça peut être des carmes manager avec des
évaluations compétences bien
effectivement et ça ça valorise radotant
on a le relayage et on en a pas pas trop
parler mais s'associe à nouveau métier
c'est des expérimentations actuellement
pour justement se substituer les dents
et avoir à relais et je crois que il ya
une chose très importante sur lequel
nous on réfléchit normalement c'est le
repérage
parce que si l'amour d'avoir poussé
dispositif toutes ces actions
d'information et où trouve-t-on les
dents et le réflexe proches aidants sont
fait partie d'ailleurs ce repérage
on doit à tout prix tout ce au niveau de
l'entreprise non pas pour désigner comme
vous disiez bacabara la personne qui
soit qu'ils soient faibles au contraire
pour trouver la personne forte qu'il
était de retour mais je vous propose
qu'on s'arrête sur ces mots ce cette ut
société maintenant terminée pour avoir
toutes les informations si vous êtes en
situation d'être et dans de nombreux
sites se sont affichées tout au long au
délai de l'émission merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau temps des
changes d'ici là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]